♪ I walk in the dark I cry
I'm sorry,
can I help you?
Oh, I'm one
of the artists.
One of the
sandwich artists?
No, I'm one of the--
the artist artists.
Have any of the pieces
sold yet?
I know it's early.
I haven't heard anything.
But I highly doubt it.
Well, no, it's just that people
don't really come in here
for the art.
We're a sandwich shop.
So we sell food.
Would you like some?
Are they...
free sandwiches?
You can order
and then pay.
Okay, so how it
usually works.
It's-- Yeah.
High-quality lotion,
I'm gonna take the lotion.
God.
(scoffs)
Gallery.
Step into reality.
Oh.
Ilana?
Are you eating
garbage bagels?
Why are you here?
Abbi sent me a Facebook invite
to her gallery debut.
Do you...
look... crazy?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, I do.
I got locked out
and then I--
I just, like, ruined
her night completely.
I'm an idiot,
I'm like a dumb ass.
I, like, can't function.
Oh, don't be so hard
on yourself.
Nobody's perfect.
I'm not
a perfect dentist.
I eat candy all the time.
I got, like,
six cavities.
Thanks-- thanks for--
Ahh!
Ooh, what?
Oh.
Oh, my God.
The keys to
my apartment.
Don't you ever
tell Abbi.
You can't ever tell her.
You can't ever tell her this,
this is--
I won't tell Abbi, but I've
told you several times
and I'll
tell you again,
phone, keys, wallet--
Every time.
Phone, keys,
wallet, P-K-W.
Your brain is a muscle, Ilana,
and I feel like that muscle
isn't getting
enough exercise.
You need to do your
brain kegels.
And five.